when I was running for congress that I
just had to take some time of
introspection just like
I I am pursuing this path of service
that I've committed my life to and yet
there are these self kind of created
hurdles of anxiety just because of that
that shyness and I I looked myself in
the mirror and I was like what's what's
your problem
well you got to figure this out and and
really just taking that time made me
realize that all of those fears and
insecurities the causes of that anxiety
were actually very selfish because I was
thinking like well
you know I don't want to sound stupid
what if they ask me a question I don't
know the answer to and I don't want to
bother them and and the common the
common word that came up as I was going
through this was was I and me I'm like
well that's a problem
especially as as you know I I had made
this decision to to pursue this path of
service and and so that was that was
where things changed where instead of
walking into a room something that would
cause anxiety and anyone who's an
introvert and shy you can probably
relate
was turned around when I realized like
stop thinking about yourself Kelsey go
in this room and and take the
opportunity to connect with other people
to share Aloha with them to smile have a
nice conversation at a bare minimum and
once I shifted my focus on uh in that
way uh it changed everything I love it
because when when you when we watch you
on stage and uh Kamala goes after you
and then you go to back and forth when
Kamala and Biden were going job we're
going back and forth and you came in and
Bowman and the comments about Hillary
and what she said about you and
everybody's wondering how you're going
to react and your reaction was even
stronger than the way she did it and
then you see this person you're like
this This Woman's got Poise strength
courage confidence is willing to stand
up for herself these are not qualities
of somebody that's timid or shy so it's
great that that transition happened to
you but the question you read a lot I
think to to your point on that
um
it it all I mean it is all rooted in a
place of of uh
intentionally every day uh choosing to
not put myself first service above self
and so as attacks are coming or what are
all of these other things that are
happening whether it was in the past or
just the stuff that we're dealing with
now on a daily basis you talked about
some of the things in your introduction
um for me recognizing it's not about me
so all this stuff is just like I'm not
in it for me uh the attacks can roll off
my shoulder and let me stay focused on
my mission is genuinely genuinely have
that mindset where it's about
service to others and helping the
country country first versus sort of
being an egomaniac I want to have power
I want to have notoriety unfortunately
not very many even though we hear these
words very often coming from politicians
the actions tell another story and this
was one of the most disheartening things
that I found when I was in Congress for
eight years was how many people in in
the house in the Senate their whole
identity is centered around this title
and so when when that is their identity
and I've seen this with people who've
left Congress and found themselves
feeling very uh almost worthless or
irrelevant because people aren't
inviting them to things anymore people
aren't asking them hey what's your
opinion on this and so for those who are
there you you can see how
they are willing to do whatever it takes
to keep that position or to climb to a
higher position because unfortunately
that's where they find their their self
is that one of the main reasons why
there there's no progress on term limits
in Congress just because the people
voting for it just don't want to leave I
I think there's that that's that's one
motivator
um it's also uh you know one of the
reasons why we see this endless uh
search and ambition for just more power
and more control because ultimately what
it comes down to it is about them rather
than saying hey we and this this applies
to both political parties as well their
well-being their means of existence
rather than like all right guys we have
very real problems how do we sit down
and figure out how to solve these
problems in a real and Lasting way and
and for those conversations uh we're
seeing some of them play out right now
or with the debt ceiling issue but we
see how these things just don't happen
very often so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]